[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar influenza an underestimated
threat
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
ari frankel chief science officer arc
stone medical solutions dr frenkel you
may now begin your presentation
thank you for the introduction it's an
honor to be presenting today before we
start some disclosures as you can see on
this introduction slide
i want to also go into a little bit of
my background to provide some context
and objectives
we at arcstone use prescribe responsibly
as our banner in an effort to bring
awareness to antibiotic over utilization
and our fight against antimicrobial
resistance
but one can only do this if our
understanding of infectious diseases and
how we treat these infections is optimal
my objective as always is to change the
way people understand infectious disease
so that we can use the best available
evidence to treat these infections
i'm a board certified infection disease
physician i'm also board certified in
internal medicine i have been in the
infectious disease space pretty much my
entire career
i sat in roles such as medical directors
in many settings including rural
hospitals and large corporate settings
managing multiple hospitals
i've dedicated my career to
antimicrobial stewardship and changing
the way healthcare providers prescribe
antibiotics
as co-founder and chief science officer
of arcstone we use technology and
artificial intelligence to bring the
tools healthcare providers need to
understand infectious disease and
participate in a efficient and optimal
antimicrobial stewardship
so let's jump right into it
in the last several years kova 19 has
been the focus and forefront of public
health medicine in general and
infectious disease what a lot of
clinicians saw almost immediately was
that other medical conditions were put
on the wayside
colleagues of mine noted that patients
were avoiding care of other chronic
conditions in fear of cover 19.
we also saw that coca-19 was the focus
of infectious disease testing while many
other respiratory pathogens were and
still are capable of causing diseases
many of which present similarly to
cova-19
many patients with viral upper
respiratory symptoms would obtain cover
19 testing and when negative workup was
discontinued
with no underlying diagnosis and no
additional testing for other pathogens
that may be contagious or cause similar
symptoms
influenza is one of those pathogens that
can be that can present very similar to
cover 19 and can be overlooked if cova
19 is the only micro being tested for
when kova 19 pandemic started many
people compared it to influenza and they
compared it to the impact influenza had
in the pandemics influenza caused
many years earlier
many people are unaware of the history
of influenza
and that
influenza was a significant and still
remains a significant threat
in the last hundred years influenza has
resulted in four pandemics and several
epidemics
the spanish flu of 1918 to 1919 caused
by h1n1 was responsible for 50 million
debts worldwide including 675 000 deaths
in the united states alone asian flu
caused by h2n2 in 1957
caused 1.1 million deaths worldwide and
116 000 deaths in the u.s alone
the hong kong flu caused by h3n2 caused
1 million vets worldwide and 100 000
deaths in the united states
and lastly the swine flu caused by h1n1
most recently in 2009
caused approximately 151 000 to 575 000
deaths in the world and 12 469 deaths in
the united states
it doesn't take much to realize that
influenza is a global threat
however we can see
in this graph that when we compare each
pandemic caused by influenza there was a
dramatic decline in death toll across
each one
50 million deaths dropped to 1.1 million
deaths and approximately 39 years later
when the next pandemic arose
we saw that significant decrease
only 11 years later the next pandemic
hit and we also saw a slight decline in
mortality
lastly in the most recent influenza
pandemic we saw 575 000 deaths a
significant decline in the death toll by
approximately over 50 percent
we may be able to attribute the decline
in mortality to modern medicine
vaccinations and understanding of
infection control and public health
measures
the widespread exposure to influenza may
have helped as well as the majority of
people have had either exposure to
influenza or vaccinations which may help
with immunity and also lessen severity
of disease and the spread of disease
however it's important to note that even
after 2009 influenza pandemic we still
see thousands of deaths yearly in the
united states and worldwide caused by
this influenza virus
in jo in january 2011 the cdc estimated
that the 2009 h1n1 caused illness in
more than 60 million americans leading
to more than 270 000 hospitalization and
12
500 deaths
contrary to typical seasons 90 of
hospitalizations and deaths occurred in
persons younger than age 65.
so knowing how dangerous influenza is
where did it all come from
influenza is believed to exist for at
least 1500 years
some say that hippocrates described
influenza and his works although many
argue that this was not the case
it wasn't until richard shope isolated
the virus from infected pigs that
influenza was actually confirmed
prior to richard schope's discovery many
assumed that syndromes caused by
influenza were caused by a bacteria
called bacillus influenzae and this was
what people initially thought the 1918
pandemic was a result of
however as we know now that was not the
case and resources never researchers
never isolated that they are suspected
bacteria
there are many types of influenza
viruses and many subtypes
influenza a and influenza b are the most
common types seen clinically while
influenza c is rarely reported
with the abuse of advanced molecular
diagnostics we do see influenzae
occasionally however
animal to human transmission and human
to animal transmission is an important
element in understanding
influenza
humans can get h1n1 and h3n2
and animals can get these viruses as
well as seen with swine
horses can get h3n8 dogs can get h3n2
and certain birds can get h5n1
it's important to note that even though
many animals get infected with the same
virus as humans they are technically
different strains of this virus
the cdc notes that influenza a virus
typically
that are typically endemic in one animal
species can sometimes cause illness in
another species for example until 1998
only h1n1 viruses circulated widely in
the u.s pig population however in 1998
the h3n2 virus from humans were
introduced into the pig population and
caused widespread disease among pigs
more recently the h5n1 virus from birds
have caused sporadic infection in wild
foxes in the us and other countries this
is a quote by the cdc
but why is this important
the answer is viral reassortment
viral reassortment is the takeaway point
here this is an evolutionary mechanism
that emerges with interspecies
transmission
genes are shuffled so to speak between
viruses producing new strains of the
virus
so we don't just see this with influenza
but with many other viruses as well this
is a biological mechanism an
evolutionary mechanism
examples of this of this are the
following
in 1957 and 1968 pandemic viruses have
been determined to be reassortment of
the avian virus into human virus genetic
background
the h5n1 virus circulating between 1997
and 2007 apparently arose from multiple
resort reassortment events among avian
influenza viruses
and the 2009
h1n1 influenza pandemic emerged as a
result of triple reassortment between
avian human and swine viruses
when discussing the epidemiology of
influenza it's important to take into
consideration how the virus is
transmitted and that is mainly through
person to person
by a large droplets
and as we noted some interspecies
transmission occurs as well again
influenza a is found in humans and
animals influenza b and c mainly in
humans
influenza is a seasonal virus and occurs
more frequently in different parts of
the year
depending on your location
october to april
or may in the northern hemispheres april
to september in the southern hemispheres
and year round in tropical climates
this virus may be contagious in adults
one day before symptoms arise and even
contagious six to seven days after
symptoms begin
in children the virus may be contagious
10 or more days after symptoms begin
here we see a diagram of droplet
precautions this is the difference than
airborne precautions the distance large
droplets can travel in the air is much
less than airborne spread
once the virus enters the respiratory
tract it attaches to respiratory cells
the trachea and the bronchi when the
virus replicates these cells are
destroyed and it results in the virus
spreading and can lead to respiratory
failure
because the virus replicates in the
respiratory tract mucus saliva and
respiratory secretions can carry the
virus and spread it from person to
person the virus is typically contagious
for five to ten days as noted before
the virus's clinical presentation can
vary from mild like cold like symptoms
such as a runny nose sore throat
headache fevers
to gi illness like vomiting and diarrhea
to even more serious diseases such as
pneumonia respiratory failure septic
shock myocarditis and pericarditis
other key points to note is the
incubation period which is two days
and the resolution of fevers which
typically occurs approximately three to
four days into the infection
most symptoms resolve by day seven
however the most vulnerable population
is patients over 65 years old
super infections or infections that can
occur after or with influenza include
staph aureus strep and hemophilus
influenza
testing for the flu is relatively simple
these days there are typically two
modalities of
of testing antigen testing and molecular
testing
how specific or sensitive this test is
is a way to measure
the testing's capabilities
when something is more sensitive
it means the test has the ability to
correctly identify the patients with the
disease
when a test is specific it means that
the test has the ability to correctly
identify people without the disease
according to some studies antigen
testing is very specific but lacks
sensitivity meaning it can fail to
identify patients who are true positive
stated differently the antigen test can
rule in a disease but is poor at ruling
out the disease while molecular tests
are good for both ruling out the disease
and ruling in the disease
new technologies such as multiplex pcr
allows for testing of multiple viruses
and other potential pathogens in a
single test using a single sample
so if a patient has respiratory symptoms
consistent with a wide range of
pathogens say for example influenza rsv
cova 19 and rhinovirus a respiratory
panel testing for multiple viruses
simultaneously can aid in the diagnosis
of this infection rapidly and accurately
this provides many advantages when
compared to singleplex pcr which only
detects a single micro per sample
management of influenza depends on the
clinical scenario with most antivirals
having benefit within 48 hours of
symptoms however
we have many antivirals to choose from
each with pros and cons beyond the scope
of this lecture tamiflu is the most
commonly known antiviral fun influenza
synamovir is also another antiviral
however this one can't be given to
children who are less than eight years
old or with a history of asthma or copd
balox server is a newer antiviral
and apparently has greater reduction in
viral shedding than tamiflu
it's similar
for influenza a but superior for
influenza b according to some studies
there are some other antivirals but only
available in iv formulation
of course supportive care such as
symptomatic medications and oxygen if
necessary as well as hydration should
always be provided if needed
antimicrobial stewardship is key as
antibiotics are not necessarily needed
when treating flu
unfortunately we see that many
respiratory infections are treated with
antibiotics despite the fact that the
causes are viral and will not respond to
antibiotics
cova 19
has led to excessive antibiotic use and
exacerbation of antibiotic resistance
with that being said
there are scenarios where super
infections do occur especially when
patients improve initially and then
deteriorate afterwards common causes are
strep and staff as noted earlier
prevention of influenza is key to
stopping transmission of the virus and
reducing the intensity of disease there
are many types of vaccines available
including inactivated live attenuated
and recombinant like the treatment of
influenza each of these vaccines have
different advantages
however all people great all
people greater than six months of age
should receive the influenza vaccine
with minimal exceptions
as we discussed earlier due to antigenic
drift immunity is typically less than a
year
with efficacy of the vaccine at 40 to 60
at times although very variable
vaccinations of influenza have led to
fewer deaths among children and fewer
complications in general
other important modalities of preventing
influenza
is post-exposure prophylaxis which is
when an individual who may have been
exposed to influenza
receives antivirals soon after in order
to prevent disease progression and
possible transmission to others
contraindications to vaccines include
any type of allergies to vaccine
component
although typically rare
there is a lot of confusion as how
vaccines work and this can be a lecture
onto itself however generally speaking
the vaccine stimulates the body's immune
system so that when an actual infection
occurs the immune system is ready and
prepared to neutralize and reduce the
spread of infection subsequently
reducing the risk of transmission
the influenza vaccine is safe and
millions of americans around the world
received this vaccine for over 50 years
the benefits outweigh the risks and the
side effects of the vaccine
have been evaluated extensively and
rigorously in many studies
unfortunately a recent study has shown
that only 50 percent of medicare
recipients had claims from influenza
vaccines
meaning half the patients did not
receive a vaccine influence influenza
my final takeaway points and objectives
of this lecture
is that influence is very dangerous and
can often be overlooked especially
within the setting of cover 19.
influenza has caused millions of deaths
in the last 100 years it has led to
multiple pandemics and has the potential
to lead to even more pandemics in the
future
we have the ability to rule out
influenza along with other dangerous
viruses using advanced technology and
testing with advances in medicine we
also have many treatment options should
one get influenza
but most importantly vaccines still
remain the primary method to prevent
severe illness and the spread of disease
i want to thank everybody for their time
and i would like to address any
questions anybody may have
thank you
thank you dr frenkel for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what are h and n in h1n1
sure i hope everybody can hear me okay
uh so the h and the n stand for proteins
found on the virus h is hemoglobin and
is neuraminase and again it's a little
bit beyond the uh scope of the lecture
but those are proteins found on
the outer shell of the virus
and different viruses are known to have
different proteins
there are about 16 hemoglobins and
approximately nine
aramidases and what
and the way we classify influenza is by
the combination of those different
proteins so we got approximately 144
give and take combinations that we can
make out of those different proteins and
so that's how the influenza virus is
labeled
there are different types of labels that
the cdc provides for influenza as well
so it's not the only way that we that we
classify influenza
all right thank you
next question
uh can sars kobe 2 virus alpha beta
gamma delta epsilon and omicron variants
cross-speciate with influenza a b and c
if so what are current evidences
uh that i don't believe so as far as i
know currently um
i don't believe that's the case where we
can see two different types of viruses
not within the same family um
i you know um create some sort of cross
uh
or like we mentioned in the on the
lecture
i don't believe that's the case that it
can happen it's usually within the same
uh virus itself um
but and and i don't know if any data
that suggests kova 19
has that potential
all right thank you
next question
how can multiplex pcr assist labs during
the upcoming flu season with covet 19
still here
so it's a good question um so
the the
way you have to see it is that when you
have a viral syndrome when a patient
comes in sick with your classic viral
syndrome fevers coughing runny nose
headache fevers
it's very hard to know exactly what that
is and traditionally
a lot of physicians would say well the
patient has a virus and it will take its
course
but
because of new technology we have the
ability to actually diagnose these
viruses using molecular
diagnostics that uses the viruses dna or
rna to identify it
and multiplex as noted in the lecture it
gives you the ability to test for
multiple pathogens simultaneously
so if you're looking for a patient who
has general virus spiral symptoms you
could run a series of tests on them in
one shot in one sample and hopefully get
to your diagnosis
so if you're suspecting that a patient
may have coven 19 but it could also be
influenza it can also be rhinovirus a
respiratory panel may help differentiate
that this way nothing goes
undiagnosed great thank you
next question
can a recent covit 19 infection protect
against influenza
i don't believe that's the case uh
usually we will get immunity from
viruses either through vaccinations that
are specifically designed for that virus
or by being exposed to that virus
and natural immunity occurs
but cross-immunity to my knowledge will
not happen between influenza and cover
19 and that was
one of the reasons why coconut 19 when
the pandemic started was a significant
issue because we didn't have anything
available to uh to protect people uh if
the flu would provide protection then
theoretically we may have been able to
use the flu vaccine as a former vaccine
but there was no cross
um there was no cross protection on that
we sometimes see cross protection like
we will see with uh smallpox and cowpox
that was famous cross protection we saw
with that and sometimes we do see that
but not with these two viruses
all right thank you
next question
for detection of flu a or b
rt pcr how many genes should be targeted
for each to be sure that we detect it
correctly
that's a good question
i'm not exactly sure of the answer of um
of what exactly
on the molecular side they're testing
for when it comes to coca-19 generally
speaking they're looking for two or
three genes to consider that a positive
for flu i i'm not sure exactly um uh
what on on again on the lab side they're
doing
uh so i would have to defer that
question to somebody who may know
that uh part of the diagnostics better
than me
all right thank you
next question
as the influenza vaccine is now advised
to be administered at the start of the
flu season
is there an aggressive plan to educate
individuals worldwide that they should
not wait to get vaccinated each year i
know this is a common reason many
americans hold off on getting their flu
vaccination many others are also certain
they become sick from the vaccine
not considering that maybe they had
already been exposed to someone with the
flu
i think it's always a challenge
especially from the public health side
of the equation as far as educating
people on vaccines and the benefits
right now the recommendation is yearly
vaccinations for
for influenza and that hasn't changed
because influenza changes from year to
year because it's variations in the
virus
that may affect the how well the vaccine
is received and how well we have and how
protected we are with the vaccine but
that shouldn't defer people from getting
the vaccine because uh all the data
shows that
um that it's of a benefit and a little
protection sometimes is better than no
protection and we do see that data shows
that
there's clinical improvement
and better outcomes on those who are
vaccinated so we always see
a
positive
outcome on vaccinations so nobody should
wait and if you're able to get the
vaccine
that's what we should do
all right
next question
what is meant by an attenuated vaccine
so attenuated refers to a weakened virus
there's many different ways that that
vaccines can be prepared
most recently we have heard of the mrna
vaccines which is the latest technology
that we use for covid
but sometimes
and again going back the objective of a
vaccine is to almost trick your body's
immune system
to uh thinking it's infected so uh ways
that we do that is introduce proteins of
the virus sometimes we actually
introduce the virus but a weakened
version of it
and that will basically have your body
react to the virus as if you're being
infected which prepares your bio your
body to fight in the true infection or
real infection when it happens so
attenuated is a weakened
uh version of the virus so that the
virus can't actually cause the infection
but it's introduced so that your body
thinks that it's being infected and can
protect you from real infection in the
future
all right thank you
next question
how can we estimate future interactions
between covet 19 and influenza do we
believe the dramatic drops in the 2020
and 2021 flu rates were associated more
with covid19 npis
or kova 19 having an antagonistic effect
so i think that the answer to that
question will come as we get more data
once we analyze what's been happening in
the last couple of years there's a lot
of co-founding
i think elements to this when uh as i
noted in the lecture we saw that there
was a heavy focus on testing for cova 19
so there could be some bias that people
weren't being tested necessarily for for
influenza and naturally that would shift
our diagnostics and our numbers
we also know that people were taking
extra precautions because of cover 19 in
a pandemic wearing masks and isolation
and shutdowns and that could have also
affected the spread of cover 19
and influenza but there was some concern
um and there's still this concern as the
impact of influenza causing severe
illness and covenant 19 because now
cover 19 is a new player so to speak in
our respiratory infection so
i think that we're
we're still
learning more about how they're going to
interact together and how it's going to
change
basically our mortality when it comes to
respiratory infections
all right thank you
next question
are the rate of mutations in the flu
virus as the same as for the covavirus
uh thankfully no um influenza is i
believe uh and again i i'm not an expert
in uh the microbiology influenza but i
do believe influenza does have the
propensity to
shift or change uh more frequently than
cova 19. in fact one of the concerns was
when kova 19 came out is how well will
the vaccine work against coca-19 do we
have to be concerned that it's going to
be similar to kova 19 i mean sorry
similar to influenza in the sense that
the vaccine needs to change from year to
year so as we know now cover 19 has
changed uh and we do see different
variants of kova 19 but it's not to the
extent that we see at this point have
that we've seen influenza although this
could change again cover 19 is evolving
data so that may change over time
and we have seen more variants of cover
19 than i think we initially expected to
see so uh so the answer to sum it up is
uh i don't know yet whether or not
that's the case
all right
thank you
next question do you know if there is a
difference in terms of sensitivity and
specificity of antigen testing from
nasopharyngeal swabs versus
bronchoalveolar lavage of course when
the material type collection is chosen
according to the respiratory symptoms
and the stage of infection
that's a good question and that's a
difficult one to answer because it
depends on the equipment that you're
using
and whether or not it's indicated for
that so we also saw this with kova 19
whether or not
we could take samples or oral pharyngeal
samples versus these referendum samples
and uh that depended on whether or not
the equipment uh and and the type of
swab so there's a lot of factors as to
whether or not there could be something
that can impede the detection the the
reason why nasopharyngeal was the
preferred is because of where the virus
where you find concentrations or
colonization
of the virus and where you're most
likely to get highest yield from it
but we do see that changing so um so i
don't know the answer to that question
necessarily as far as whether or not
we'll see
one
equal
diagnostic abilities but the testing and
the molecular diagnostic diagnostics is
getting better and more sensitive so i
wouldn't be surprised if we can obtain
the sample from really anywhere
and um and and it would still be an
accurate test
all right thank you
and we will wrap up with this last
question
are both influenza a and b shed in the
gi tract
generally speaking the virus will is
found in the respiratory tract and it's
transmitted through the droplets because
as we noted in the lecture we'll see
uh the virus shed in the uh and it would
use the cells the in the trachea and the
bronchi eye that's where it replicates
so we that's where the virus is spread
from and that's generally where we that
where we check to see whether or not
patients have the virus that's where
we're doing a respiratory sample to
detect the virus whether we can detect
the virus in the gi tract
and in uh
that's something that i have not seen
people use that um i'm not actually sure
as far as uh the incidence of detecting
the virus in the gi tract it's a good
question
i'm sure if a patient is vomiting we may
be able to detect virus in in that fluid
whether or not we'll detect it in other
areas of the
gi tract i'm just not sure but anytime
we do diagnostics we want to go with the
highest yield and we want to go into the
source of where we can get that and for
influenza it's generally speaking it's
going to be the respiratory tract
great thank you and i've just been
notified because we were getting so many
great questions uh that we have time for
two more if if you mind sticking with us
um
so do you anticipate seeing mrna vaccine
development for influenza viruses in the
future
i think so um and again i don't have
access to uh any
more information than what the cdc
provides or uh
or uh general information that i can
find but based on what we saw with the
uh kova 19 virus how effective the
vaccines were how fast they were to uh
and to basically uh
create
i think that mrna vaccines will be the
future of how we make vaccines let's
talk about using damarane technology for
a wide variety of different pathogens
that in the past we've may have not
thought about exploring vaccinations for
so
mrna vaccinations open up a whole new
world for uh for vaccines so i would
expect that we will see this um it's
just my suspicion i could be wrong but i
think we will see this for influenza as
well
all right
and our last question
could mrna vaccines
be more effective in preventing
influenza
good question
it's hard to say because again the fact
when we
give somebody a vaccine our purpose is
to introduce to the body a pseudo
infection a a false sense that there's
an infection happening ultimately it's
the body's
reaction to that to build up immunity so
mrna vaccinations achieve the same thing
whether or not the immune response is
going to be higher for an influenza
vaccine through mrna versus the
traditional methods is yet to be seen
because we would have to study that we'd
have to know
uh and do a comparable study as to
whether patients with mrna vaccines do
better than those patients with
traditional vaccines so it's really hard
to say at this point and uh and really
the carbon 19 was uh our first public
approach with mrna vaccination so as we
roll out that new technology we may end
up we may end up having the answer to
that question
all right thank you dr frenkel do you
have any final comments for our audience
no just thank you very much for uh
attending and on hearing what i have to
say i hope you learned something um from
the lecture and i hope this helps spread
awareness that there are
many things to worry about but uh we
could tackle them we've done a great job
with influenza overall if you see that
slide where we saw we saw how
the change in the death toll from 1918
to 2009 how drastic that was we've
learned a lot from influenza we've
learned a lot from cover 19 so hopefully
we can take this information and we can
use it so that the next round of
pandemics which are bound to happen
where we approach it much differently
all right well thank you again dr
frenkel for your time today and your
wonderful presentation you're welcome we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you